sanktionen gegen china die usa reagieren
auf die einschränkung der autonomie in
hongkong peking kündigte gegenmaßnahmen
an nicht mehr rein und nicht mehr aus
deutschland diskutiert über mögliche
lokale reiseverbote wenn die korona
zahlen örtlich steigen
parits gesetz gekippt das
verfassungsgericht in thüringen stoppt
die vorgabe für die parteien ihre
kandidatenlisten abwechselnd mit frauen
und männern zu besetzen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend seien sie
willkommen bei den heute nachrichten um
19 uhr die wir mit dem immer schärfer
werdenden konflikt zwischen china und
den usa beginnen
denn mit den neuen sogenannten
sicherheitsgesetz für hongkong hat china
aus sicht der usa den bogen überspannt
statt die autonomie dort zu respektieren
habe peking den menschen ihre freiheit
weggenommen wie us-präsident trump sagt
als konsequenz drohen die usa nun mit
sanktionen
die zunehmenden rivalität der beiden
weltmächte sie zeigt sich aktuell an
diesen streitpunkten dem handelskonflikt
der schon zweieinhalb jahre anhält oder
trans spionage vorwürfen gegen den
technologiekonzern way
außerdem sind der pekings
gebietsansprüche im südchinesischen meer
oder die weltweite verbreitung des
corona virus für die trump china
verantwortlich macht
über die entwicklungen rund um hongkong
jetzt ulf röller manning gibt gerne
unterricht und sie lebt gerne in
hongkong aber die musiklehrerin plant
nach australien auszuwandern wie sie
wollen viele die stadt verlassen denn
sie fühlen ihre freiheit von china
bedroht
die kommunistische partei chinas ist
eine teuflische macht egal wo du lebst
sie verfolgt dich das muss die welt
verstehen
us-präsident trampel der welt beweisen
dass er das versteht er segnete weitere
sanktionen gegen china appetit wird der
wirtschaftliche sonderstatus hongkongs
beendet bei diesem gesetz haben wir die
möglichkeit personen und organisationen
zur verantwortung zu ziehen
die hongkongs freiheit auslöschen die
reaktion ließ aus peking nicht lange auf
sich warten
china droht mit vergeltung keine
ausländische macht hat das recht sich
einzumischen
china hat den unerschütterlichen willen
seine nationale souveränität zu schützen
in hongkong kämpfen viele weiter für
ihre freiheit im september will die pro
demokratie bewegung bei den
parlamentswahlen die mehrheit erringen
uns zu wählen gibt uns eine stimme die
man dann weltweit hört wir geben nicht
auf
chinas präsident wird seinen hongkong
kurs trotz sanktionen beibehalten
vor allem glaubt er nicht dass die
europäer sich den us strafmaßnahmen
anschließen werden dafür hält er sie für
zu abhängig von chinas wirtschaft
us-präsident trump nimmt immer mehr
china ins visier
hongkong ein schauplatz für das duell
der weltmächte
er fragt sich wohin diese kraftprobe
noch führt und wie sie ausgeht elmar
theveßen in washington
vordergründig geht es natürlich auch ein
stück weit um wahlkampf donald trump
china zum großen wahlkampfthema machen
will
er will china die schultern der korona
krise geben aber in wirklichkeit geht es
hier um viel mehr die usa sehen china
als den grossen widersacher der zukunft
autoritarismus gegen liberale demokratie
oder sind sich übrigens republikaner und
demokraten hier auch 100 prozent einig
beide seiten unterstützen jetzt die
maßnahmen sie unterstützen auch die
entsendung der flugzeugträger gruppen in
das südchinesische meer
es gibt ein bisschen kritik daran dass
man hong kong jetzt einfach so china
zuschlägt dieses signal jedenfalls
sendet genau das wollte das regime in
peking
ja aber im großen und ganzen ist man
sich einig und ich glaube wir haben es
hier mit so einer art vorboten für einen
möglichen neuen kalten krieg zu tun in
dem sich dann auch die europäischen
verbündeten entscheiden müssen auf
welcher seite sie stehen
und das ist unabhängig von der frage wer
im nächsten jahr hier im weißen haus
dann präsident ist ob donald trump oder
der demokrat joe biden düsterer
ausblicke vielen dank mrt wissen für
ihre analyse schauen wir auf die korona
zahlen in deutschland die bleiben weiter
stabil
im durchschnitt der letzten sieben tage
haben sich täglich 300 menschen neu
angesteckt das ist der gleiche stand wie
gestern
was aber wenn es doch zu lokalen
ausbrüchen kommt wie zuletzt im
landkreis gütersloh bei der firma
tönnies ganz schnell sehen sich dann
bewohner mit einreisebeschränkungen
konfrontiert wie zuletzt in österreich
oder an der ostsee
besser wäre es menschen aus solchen hot
spots würden ihren wohnort gar nicht
erst verlassen meinen viele
es wird heiß diskutiert über dieses
thema christoph distel berichtet als
corona in gütersloh ausbrach bekamen die
menschen zwar einen lock down
verschrieben aber in sachen reisen nur
eine dünne empfehlung lieber nicht um
dann etwa auf der insel usedom zu hören
für euch ist hier kein platz
auch deswegen findet die kanzlerin
findet der bayerische ministerpräsident
am besten man ließ sie die leute bei
virus alarm gar nicht erst weg nur wenn
alles gleich ganze landkreise absperren
die verantwortlichen vor ort winken da
ab ein großes problem wird sein wenn ich
eine reisebeschreibung habe dass ich
auch kontrollieren muss und wenn ich mir
vorstelle ich habe so einen riesen
landkreis in mecklenburg vorpommern mit
5000 quadratkilometern größe wie will
ich da eine solche reise beschränkung
tatsächlich für das gesamte kreisgebiet
überwachen wollen den güterslohern wurde
noch geraten test machen am reiseziel
vorzeigen dabei ergibt es wäre logisch
betrachtet durchaus sinn den nächsten
hotspot von vornherein abzuriegeln
aber nur wenn die lage wirklich außer
kontrolle ist das macht epidemiologisch
dann sind wenn man viele einzelne fälle
hat bei denen man in einem landkreis die
infektionsketten nicht nachvollziehen
kann also viele auf einmal wo man nicht
weiß wo es herkommt in solchen fällen
kann das ausnahmsweise mal sinnvoll sein
egal wer hier was will allen ist klar
wie tief reisesperren die persönliche
freiheit der menschen beschneiden würden
und wie heikel das juristisch ist
prinzipiell erlaubt das
infektionsschutzgesetz solche freiheits
beschränkende maßnahmen gerichte zu
letztem fall gütersloh haben aber immer
wieder klar gemacht diese maßnahmen
müssen erforderlich und verhältnismäßig
sein
ist das nicht der fall könnte auch eine
solche reise sperre rechtswidrig seien
ob der nächste corona ausbruch nun ein
hochhaus oder einen schlachthof trifft
er soll schnell und präzise eingedämmt
werden wie groß man darum den
sicherheitspreis zieht das soll morgen
entschieden werden
luxemburg liegt seit tagen über der
kritischen marke von 50 neuinfektionen
pro 100000 einwohner
deshalb warnt das auswärtige amt in
berlin vor allen nicht notwendigen
reisen dorthin
das robert koch-institut hatte luxemburg
zuvor als risikogebiet eingestuft für
berufspendler gilt die reisewarnung
nicht
schauen wir noch mal auf die firma
tönnies deutschlands größter fleisch
betrieb darf an seinem hauptsitz wieder
schlachten
rund vier wochen nach dem dortigen chor
ohne ausbruch hat die stadt den
produktionsstopp aufgehoben
der bereich in dem die tiere zerlegt
werden bleibt jedoch geschlossen
mitte juni hatten sich bei tönnies mehr
als 1500 mitarbeiter mit dem virus
infiziert lothar becker sind direkt am
werk in rheda wiedenbrück was hat zu
dieser entscheidung geführt haben sich
die arbeitsbedingungen bei turniers denn
inzwischen gravierend verändert es wurde
einiges getan an den hygienestandards so
wurden zum beispiel hepa filter
eingebaut um die luft in den anlagen
eben entsprechend zu filtern außerdem
wird diese luft auch mit uv licht
bestrahlt um auf diese art dafür zu
sorgen dass keine viren mehr ja sich in
der luft befinden und das sorgt dafür
dass heute nacht um 4 uhr die
schlachtung den betrieb wieder aufnehmen
kann man geht davon aus dass zwischen 6
und 8 tausend schweine allein morgen
getötet werden geschlachtet werden sie
können aber noch nicht zerlegt werden
denn auch in der zerlegung muss erst
noch ein so genannter kalter rauch test
durchgeführt werden dann könnte dort am
freitag ein probebetrieb wieder beginnen
in dem weißen zelt hinter mir werden
dann alle mitarbeiter die ins werk gehen
erstmal ärztlich gecheckt außerdem wird
die temperatur mit einem thermo scanner
gemessen und so möchte man hier für
absolute arbeitssicherheit sorgen und
entsprechende hygiene standards
vielen dank lothar becker nach rheda
wiedenbrück parteien in thüringen müssen
ihre wahllisten nicht abwechselnd mit
frauen und männern besetzen
das hat der verfassungsgerichtshof in
weimar entschieden und das sogenannte
parität gesetz gekippt nicht nur in
thüringen in allen deutschen
länderparlamenten sitzen deutlich
mehr männer als frauen in hamburg sind
es zwar immerhin rund 44 prozent der
abgeordneten weiblich in thüringen
dagegen nur 32 prozent schlusslicht ist
sachsen anhalt mit 22 prozent gegen den
versuch das per gesetz zu ändern klagte
die afd
mit erfolg florian coaching enttäuschte
hoffnung draußen drinnen freude auf
seiten der kläger über das gekippte
gesetz die thüringer afd
nach eigenen angaben mit 20 bis 30
prozent frauenanteil fühlte sich durch
die quote benachteiligt grundschulen zur
klage war dass dieses gesetz in eine
ganze reihe wichtiger
verfassungsrechtlicher position
unzulässig eingegriffen hat wovon die
wichtigsten aus meiner sicht sind das
aktive und passive wahlrecht und die
chancengleichheit der parteien von der
wir natürlich als a4 besonders betroffen
gewesen wären
mit sechs zu drei stimmen haben die
richter entschieden unter anderem weil
das paritätsprinzip freiheit der wahl
eingegriffen habe
der verfassungsgerichtshof hat
klargestellt dass die gleichstellung von
frauen ein staatliches ziel ist und dass
auch legitim ist aber eine starre quoten
regelung so wie es das gesetz vorgesehen
hat gegen die verfassung verstößt
vor gut einem jahr hatte rot rot grün in
thüringen die regelung durchgesetzt mit
dem ziel mehr frauen ins parlament
immerhin schaffe das heutige urteil
rechtssicherheit für künftige wahlen und
enthalte auch ratschläge sagt thüringens
justizminister
ich denke dass darin viele wertvolle
anregungen gerade auch in den
sondervoten mit den hinweisen welche
lösungsmöglichkeiten
darin stecken wertvolle hinweise gegeben
wurden wie man das ziel weiterverfolgen
kann zum beispiel den parteien mehr zeit
zu geben mehr frauen für eine kandidatur
zu gewinnen
das thüringer urteil möglicherweise
eines mit signalwirkung auch brandenburg
hat ein parits gesetz beschlossen und
auch dort gibt es eine klage verhandelt
wird im august ein ganz anderes thema
jetzt die deutsche stahlindustrie auch
sie leidet unter der korona pandemie in
der krise ist sie aber schon lange vor
40 jahren haben in der einstigen
schlüsselindustrie 288.000 menschen
gearbeitet
heute sind es noch 86.000 billige
konkurrenz auf dem weltmarkt macht den
unternehmen zu schaffen der bund springt
den stahlwerken jetzt zur seite und will
ein wechsel hin zu klimafreundlichen
produziertem stahl klaus brodbeck die
farbe grün nicht zufällig gewählt damit
stahl aus deutschland weltweit
konkurrenzfähig bleibt soll die
produktion klimaneutral würden queen als
stahl made in germany
das heißt eine umstellung auf co2 arme
und dann perspektivisch co2 freie
stahlproduktion kann ein vorbild sein
deutschlands stahlproduktion ist in den
vergangenen zehn jahren um zehn prozent
gesunken 4000 arbeitsplätze weniger
corona wirkt wie ein brandbeschleuniger
hat aber auch dazu beigetragen dass sich
die beteiligten schnell einigen konnten
die produktion soll auf wasserstoff
technologie umgestellt langfristig also
klimaneutral werden die abwanderung von
produktionen und arbeitsplätzen in
billig standorte mit niedrigen standards
soll verhindert und der import von
ausländischem stahl nach europa an
bedingungen geknüpft die hürden also
höher werden
zugeschaltet zustimmung von wirtschaft
und gewerkschaften
jetzt kommt es darauf an diesen rahmen
weiter auszufüllen und rasch erste
schritte zur umsetzung auf den weg zu
bringen
die stahlindustrie muss dabei von der
politik unterstützt werden in alleine
würde die herausforderungen nicht
stemmen können
doch der ausbau notwendiger erneuerbare
energien stockt kritik daher von der
opposition
man kann ich auf der einen seite sagen
man will stahl mit einer wasserstoff
strategie produzieren und auf der
anderen seite ist das dass man dafür
braucht nicht erneuerbar und deswegen
ist ganz klar wir müssen hier wirklich
ein umsteuern haben 30 milliarden euro
dürfte der umbau der stahlindustrie
kosten die zukunft bleibt eine
herausforderung
und jetzt zu einer riesensumme 13
milliarden euro
die hätte der us konzern apple an irland
zahlen sollen
ginge es nach der eu-kommission eine
steuernachforderung die ein eu gericht
jetzt gekippt hat dabei geht es um einen
jahrelangen streit zwischen dem
technologieriesen und der eu kommission
die wirft apple ein illegales
steuerabkommen mit irland vor
wie soll man dieses urteil verstehen
stefan leifert in brüssel da verdient
einen us konzern in europa milliarden
und muss trotzdem kaum steuern zahlen
und das offenbar zu recht
ja so sieht es nach diesem urteil aus
und damit hat die eu kommission jetzt
schriftlich dass ihre instrumente
offenbar nicht ausreichend sind um aus
amerikanischen grosskonzern europäische
steuerzahler zu machen für die eu
kommission für brüssel ist das eine
niederlage gleich an zwei fronten zum
einen gegenüber den usa in dem bemühen
das geschäftsgebaren amerikanischer
großkonzerne hier in europa stärker zu
regulieren
donald trump wird dieses urteil heute
mit genugtuung zur kenntnis nehmen und
zweitens ist es auch eine niederlage
brüssels gegenüber ländern wie
niederlande luxemburg oder irland deren
fragwürdige steuert deals mit
amerikanischen multinationalen konzernen
waren der eu-kommission ja schon lange
ein dorn im auge dieser kampf erhält
jetzt erst einmal einen dämpfer
das urteil von heute das stärkt vor
allem all diejenigen die schon lange
dafür sind endlich eine digital steuer
auf europäischer
oder eine eu-weite unternehmenssteuer
einzuführen die eu kommission ihrerseits
gab sich heute vor allem zerknirscht sie
könnte berufung einlegen und so wie das
heute klang wird sie sich an diesen
strohhalm klammern vielen dank für ihre
erklärungen stefan leifert in brüssel
mallorca macht viele lokale wieder dicht
unter anderem waren wir so genannten
bier und der schinkenstraße am
ballermann
der tourismusminister der balearen sagt
die maßnahme gelte zunächst für zwei
monate
am wochenende hatten hunderte auf der
insel wild gefeiert ohne mundschutz und
sicherheitsabstand
unter den partygästen waren wohl vor
allem touristen aus deutschland und
großbritannien auch italien blickt in
diesen tagen gebannt auf den tourismus
die korona pandemie hat die wirtschaft
schon milliarden gekostet
urlauber sind eine wichtige
einnahmequelle aber die erste bilanz
fällt katastrophal aus die buchungen
sind im juni im vergleich zum letzten
jahr um 80 prozent eingebrochen
die tourismusbranche die immerhin 13
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes
ausmacht liegt am boden simone friedrich
die italienische adria ein beliebtes
reiseziel gerade bei den deutschen solo
hat jedes jahr mehr als fünfeinhalb
millionen urlauber dieses jahr nicht
leere strände leere hotels und damit
deren kassen und große sorgen um die
situation in jesu ich nicht sehr gut am
wochenende wir sind ausgebucht in der
woche ist situation ist nicht einfach
aber wir sind optimistisch
wochenendgäste das sind vor allem die
italiener
wenn diesen sommer beschränken sich die
meisten auf kurztrips in der nähe des
wohnortes
es fehlen also vor allem die ausländer
die mehrere wochen bleiben
eine flugreise schreckt wohl noch viele
ab jesolo ist immerhin von deutschland
aus mit dem auto zu erreichen
erstmal komisches gefühl aber wir fühlen
uns sehr wohl hier und man muss sagen
die sicherheitsstandards sind sehr hoch
wir haben lange überlegt ob wir
herkommen
aufgrund des corona virus und es war
eine gute entscheidung weil hier ist es
leer das scheint die sonne ich merke
schon dass das allgemein ein bisschen
ruhiger geworden ist
aber es freut uns einfach die italiener
auch ein stück zurück zu geben wieder
weil die hat eine sehr schwierige zeit
hier
die situation bleibt schwierig für
hotels restaurants und die vielen
kleinen shops 70 prozent weniger umsatz
in diesem mädchen dabei sind die
ausländischen gäste ihre lebensgrundlage
gerade der deutsche tourist das ist
unser freund ein treuer kunde dass die
deutschen fehlen das merkt man
nun herrscht hier eben das prinzip
hoffnung dass im juli und august auch
die italien lebenden deutschen wieder
kommen mögen
maske traten dafür hat der
geheimnisumwitterte street-art-künstler
banksy in der londoner u-bahn geworben
mit aufgesprühten ratten bildern ein
video im netz zeigt die ganze aktion
diana zimmermann zeigt uns auch wie sie
endet für menschen die die anonymität
lieben hat masken pflicht ihre vorteile
der straßenkünstler banksy etwa konnte
so ganz unauffällig seinem geschäft
nachgehen als reinigungskraft verkleidet
rang er vermutlich selbst wenn die
londoner u-bahn ein um dort mit
schablonen und spraydosen hygiene
bewusste ratten zu verewigen
wäre die britische regierung sich in der
korona krise mit verwirrenden
botschaften zur masken pflicht hervortut
ist banksy smash glasklar wenn du keine
maske trägt kapierst du es nicht
im mai hatte der künstler zum dank an
das gesundheitssystem ein krankenhaus in
southhampton verziert dort war man
schlau genug das wertvolle stück erstmal
hängen zu lassen
in der tube dagegen wurden die ratten
bereits entfernt
man habe den banksy behandelt wie jedes
andere griffity hieß es so mancher
londoner wünscht sich das unternehmen
wäre ähnlich schnell und konsequent wenn
es darum geht das tragen von masken
durchzusetzen
da nämlich macht in london tube jeder
was er will
tja millionen einfach weggewischt
aber jetzt sind hier geht es auch um
millionen zumindest für den glückspilz
mit den richtigen lottozahlen hier sind
sie sie lauten 13 14 20 25 35 47 und die
superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
der sommer zeigt sich morgen von seiner
eher kühlen seite wann es wieder wärmer
wird das erfahren wir gleich von katja
honnefer das war es von uns danke für
ihr interesse
bettina schausten erwartet sie um drei
viertel 10 zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend wieder für sie
da punkt 7
einen schönen abend wünschen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren den
pflanzen fehlt wasser in diesen teams
orangen gebieten welten sie bereits da
ist der aktuelle regen also hoch
willkommen am alpenrand dagegen und auch
in einigen regionen norddeutschlands da
gibt es noch keinen trockenstress bei
bewuchs heute nach sinken die
temperaturen am oberrhein auf 15 grad
bis auf 7 grad geht es runter im
vogtland meist liegen die werte so knapp
über 10 grad am alpenrand fällt noch
regen und es sind doch noch einige
schauer unterwegs zwischen weser und
elbe aber lockern die wolken schön auf
und morgen scheint die sonne
von sylt bis nach sachsen in diesem
streifen sind sie weit entfernt von den
regenschauern und gewittern im osten und
auch von dem neuen regen der von westen
reinzieht und sich vor allen dingen
zwischen sauerland und alpenrand
ausschüttet in den sonnigen streifen
steigen morgen die temperaturen auf 20
bis 22 grad sonst leib ist bei 14 bis 19
grad auch merklich kühler
am freitag fällt in süddeutschland noch
etwas regen
am samstag kann es hier und da mal
gewittern und die temperaturen steigen
schon bis 27 grad und am sonntag ist es
für einige vielleicht sogar schon wieder
zu heiß noch